on this episode KC stops by again
this is
ask Gary B
you know I think it was like 122 or
something we had the same count on your
shown on my short his same day yeah it
was like at the moon's alive Gary the
videos explode yeah I mean I case tell
the vaynernation
for the one or two people that don't
know who you are
this is a first time second time guest
appearance and we've only had like three
guests ever so clearly I like you a lot
case thanks for having me it's great to
be here um Who am I I make videos I have
a technology company and I'm a huge
admirer of you Gary and this wonderful
show that you've been putting out there
for all of us viewers I appreciate it so
I think we'll just get right into it I
think we had a lot of questions
yesterday kind of tweeted out that you'd
be here and people got excited you have
a new startup which I will give some
time I'd like you to talk about it for a
few minutes great but India that's why I
went on the left side I know let's get
into
the show not that you are getting better
I'm gonna have to find some new chicks
to throw you off India let's get into it
Lucy asks at the age of eighteen what's
the best way to approach a company and
ask for work experience wait and ask for
an internship you ask for work touches
as for me well a lot of people come to
companies and says like you need this
many years of a covariance not sure how
you get that experience if nobody wants
to hire you because it when you're 18
yeah I got an answer to this I mean I
think that we now live in a world KC how
many people uh how many people hit you
up on Twitter Email other platforms
comments and YouTube you must have a
gajillion how many times have you in
your career what would you say that you
started really building in to a place
where people really pinging you this is
now a two three four year phenomenon
fear for work yes yeah more like like
people that are fans have you clearly at
this point I mean I know it's it's been
a long time and now how long do you
think that I mean I think since the
first video I made went viral over 10
years of you guys so it's been pretty
consistent since I'm good how many times
have you randomly done stuff yes met
someone got on a phone how many how many
times if I could count that Gary I more
than I could ever keep track of that's
your answer
whose question Lucy that's your answer I
also the majority this entire team is
based on random [ __ ] like so so I think
you just ask as many times as possible
there are unlimited companies in a world
where you can get to almost anybody
because of Twitter again a true social
network more so than comments on content
which a lot of other platforms are email
at this point I think has been played
out it's harder to like get to people
from email but that will still work to I
think it's stunning that you can get to
most people in the world today I don't
think people are as many people are as
wired as you and I think people have
drawn the line to know but there's
plenty if we're not the only two nice
guys or believing in serendipity there
are tens of thousands wildly
accomplished CEOs co-founders that will
absolutely hire you on spec from one
request to get experience whether they
give you an internship or pay you
minimum wage or even give you a salary
it is a wider
field it's about asking yeah I mean I
would even compliment what everything
Gary just said a compliment that Lucy by
saying you also have an opportunity via
these myriad social outlets in the
internet as a whole not just to reach
out and contact people but to actually
prove yourself like if you need to show
this experience that these people are
seeking after just do it you don't need
someone's permission to do that if you
want to work in in construction build
something if you want to work on in an
automotive factory work on cars if you
want to be a filmmaker make videos you
now have these multitude of options in
front of you to show that you're capable
if you want to be a writer write
something you know what happens in that
environment if you actually have it not
everybody has it but if you actually
have it you start getting into a place
very quickly that you realize oh wait I
don't need to have a job in the first
place that that's right no longer do you
need sort of the runway to prove your
Worth on you don't need someone else's
approval you just do it yourself
scary and very hard to do it's not to be
underestimated just how challenging that
is but doesn't mean that the opportunity
isn't there and that opportunity wasn't
there 10-15 years ago but it's uniquely
there now we're byproducts of that game
my entire career is a product of that
game I had a liquor store in New Jersey
and got a $300 camera at Best Buy and
decided to make wine videos because I
want to be like Emeril wine videos slide
videos any other movin oh by the way I
didn't get weird there out of nowhere we
are screaming on Facebook live right now
be interesting to see it's a whole
different dynamic cuz he shows some of
our consume so much on Facebook live
which launched yesterday India Benjamin
asks where does confidence come from how
do you both work on that stuff I'll let
you go first here confidence I mean hold
on yeah I couldn't you didn't know the
address Gary over your left shoulder is
my electric skateboard right there I
rode that electric skateboard up here
and if there's one thing you don't want
to do while traveling 24 miles an hour
and
heavy traffic from New York City on
electric skateboard its to whip out your
phone and double-check an address
respect so you got a right back down all
right yeah it's your best question about
your outrage okay so how does one have
enough confidence to ride an electronic
skateboard 24 miles an hour in New
York's I have an answer that that's not
really a great one for people to hear so
I'm hoping you have a better answer than
I do Gary my answer goes like this I'm
one of four kids there was the firstborn
the only daughter and the baby and then
there's the Forgotten child Casey so in
my household it was like fight to
survive and my confidence was like born
into me out of a need to just exist and
be noticed and be fed now not everyone
has had the beautiful misfortune that
yielded the fortune of my childhood that
turned me into a confident person but I
think it's very different from someone
who finds themselves as an adult in a
world that this sort of thrives on those
who have confidence and being forced to
find that within yourself but one
shortcut I have found that is by making
something making anything whether that's
writing something whether it's something
creative whether it's something more
pragmatic whether that's a relationship
whether that's a friendship if you
generate something you can take sort of
you take comfort in what it is that you
just made in your yield and I think
that's a really great shortcut to
finding confident Casey answer the give
me a word association play real quick
here fear illness illness yes I really
didn't want you to go there
thanks for screwing up my answer um for
me I only think the listening is the
lining I'm scared by the way me that's
really funny actually that's really
interesting because I'm just i was
dissing a little bit and now i'm gonna
put you on a pedestal it is literally
the health and well-being of the people
idle i weirdly for me it's the people i
love is scary ass crap for me it's it's
a very big challenge and we all go
through it and so I'm with you a net
where I was going with that is this I
I'm not scared to fail by any stretch of
the imagination and it comes in the form
of truly being in this weird place where
I really don't give a rat's ass what
anybody thinks
and it's and again that's wiring how
does one work on that what do you think
I said the only thing I go in my room
like don't care what anybody thinks
don't care what anybody like you don't
do that okay you get made fun of a lot
in high school and it seems like the
entire world is falling apart because
you're being picked diving on people to
make you you grow up and you realize it
doesn't matter what other I do Ania you
really don't I really doesn't and you
don't shading that it's like those last
two weeks of high school if you can
capture that feeling those last two
weeks in high school literally everybody
stops caring what anybody thinks cuz
you're all going somewhere else and so
I've always had that feeling it's crazy
how you know with I was born with
confidence I truly believe that I do
believe in my case I also have the
fortunate aspects of coming from a
struggle place in a different way on the
flip side my mom I was the firstborn the
apple of my mom's eye and so I had
massive positive reinforcement which
then just made me feel entitled to
success in an environment where I was
failing classes I was 4 foot 11 when I
went into my freshman year of high
school not so strong of a situation but
I walked out I mean my bookbag was
bigger you where's your big book bag
like decorate it not on the stand right
here like I literally like my book bag
was like your size like like let me tell
you a story about my freshman year ninth
day of school I'm walking down the
hallway I'm late for a class I have a
Jordache book bag that's twice the size
of me I'm walking it's like eight
minutes after the bell rang I'm lost as
[ __ ] because we have a huge high school
I have no idea where I am this is
terrible right there's some dude hanging
out of class with Paige parlo who's one
of the hottest girls in our school it's
80s in the school I know where she is
she's a sophomore he's a senior I'm
walking by them he goes like oh I go
yeah he goes the nursery schools over
there that's
what happened to me do you know what I
went through what went through my mind I
said wait wait face Punk
sorry India that's what went through my
mind and that's just where I've always
been I know it's a little crude ah
Vader cut folks all right let's get some
previous blushing right now all the time
so it was really pleasurable hey Alan s
Casey how are you defined a beam as a
success or not if you haven't already I
definitely haven't already a beam which
is my technology startup here's some
context like that updo rock in the will
incubate in the YouTube post let's make
sure everyone in fact I put a link down
below that if you click on it will
automatically unlock beam for you and
you will automatically be following
geared like that we're working it's a
new product we got cause if you take
that in the history of social social
networks there's maybe been what what
would you say how many have six years
seven seven that is the swimming pool
that we are currently waiting around in
so to call yourself a success and then I
think we define that a success of like
such meaningful scale financial
stability looking like it's going to go
into action social in things like that
warm to me that is a success and I mean
it when you can count it on less than
two hands how many companies have
succeeded it's not just catching a
unicorn it is the most the rarest
hardest thing you could ever hope to
accomplish in the space of technology
that's what we're trying to do so have I
considered it a success not even close
ask me in four or five years click the
app
yeah I mean I look to me one could argue
that it's a success right now the amount
of people that I come across who are
doing other things in their career that
want to go then make a app that has the
ambition to win the consumer web game is
extraordinarily high the amount that
even saw the day of light even saw the
day of light with well financed funding
repetitive with with money with all the
things going in their way is very small
then to have that happen on top of which
to have a very smart your tremendous
marketer you know that means a lot to me
you know I'm sure you define yourself in
a lot of different ways but your
marketing skills are very high I admire
them the amount of the amount of noise
and excitement that was generated felt
amazing to me then you got to back it up
so now this next challenge now is the
tough part is actually making the
product at that level so yeah I mean
some of them are you trapping a news I'm
sorry don't do a new one if it's done
it's done cool all right we just lost
our Facebook but some some of the
greatest failures ever were a gigantic
pile an aggregate of tiny successes so I
appreciate everything you just said and
I really hold dear the tiny successes
we've had 60 seconds for everybody's
watching what it is how you describe in
60 lip stuff but what beam is is beam as
a way of sharing via video the tiny
moments you experience in life and doing
it in a way that's absolutely dynamic
but doesn't interrupt the moment and
within this 60-second window I can
demonstrate to you exactly how that
happens and it looks like this like
right now I'm capturing video of this
entire set of Gary's beautiful face just
like that and when you hear the noise
that means it's been shared to all of my
followers that's what be you know what I
love but you'll never be able to see
what you just share it well not until
it's live in the network and everybody
else can and that's the whole idea is to
remove the scrutiny is to remove sort of
controlling the image of yourself in
your life that you put out there I like
to say beam is not about sharing how the
world sees you it's sharing how you see
the world and what's interesting about
that is what's really happening in
social is is platforms are showing who
you want to be to the world we are all
living in the most PR version of
ourselves
we have fifteen-year-old girls running
around America right now who are massive
growth hackers who understand the speed
in which likes come in on an Instagram
photo that took them 17 minutes to take
and then they take it down within the
first 60 seconds because they don't like
the data that's coming back is fast and
they reset literally three hour dynamics
to pull off the one picture that's going
to capture the moment of that concert
you went to which is PR at its finest
it's an interesting dynamic yeah we're
trying to get away from that because I
think like our the ethos the principle
behind this our mission statement is to
is to promote understanding by sharing
perspective and I think like you can tap
into other people's perspectives you had
a better idea as to what the world is
around it when I decide I'm an investor
when I really got excited I'm still
excited for this moment is the thought
of like the first time I go on stage and
beam to me is so exciting like literally
people seeing what I get to see when I
give these keynotes versus watching me
is an exciting moment for me do you know
and we can stop talking about being in a
second but last night a friend of mine
named Shawn shonduras you know and yeah
I'm snapchat Shawn beamed his daughter
being born what I mean my wife and I
watched it this morning in bed and we're
both crying I mean it was unbelievable
it wasn't the yucky stuff and it wasn't
his stuff that you would deem
inappropriate but it was his wife in the
bin the chair in the bed being anxious
and then the next shot he's holding his
beautiful newborn baby's girl and it was
such an emotional such a real raw thing
and that's we're hoping to accomplish
she didn't think he just shared love it
next question Alex asks what advice
would you give to a high school student
struggling to decide what to pursue as a
future career I've got an answer get
busy
do something do anything and one of my
favorite piece of advice is to exactly
what you should do is do something you
hate like I didn't find my passion for
entrepreneurialship and filmmaking and
everything that I've done in my career I
didn't find that by doing it I found
that by scrubbing pots in a really
terrible seafood restaurant because when
you spend 50 hours a week scrubbing pots
it's 50 hours a week you're obsessing
what you wish you were doing sitting
around playing video games in your
parents sweet house is the worst way to
find your mission in life doing
something staying busy is a really
really easy path to find something you
truly want to invest yourself in I would
also then say to recognize that playing
video games in your parents sweet house
is probably your outlet to success in
your career I would say that your
ultimate strengths and wants are the
quickest gateway drug to upside once you
recognize that there's something to be
done there too many of you and in the
world don't believe that the thing they
like doing the most has financial upside
we've drawn a line in the sand that the
thing we like is what we do it when we
have time to do it like and the other
places they either make money or get by
to so many people in the other bucket or
driven by I'm going to go into finance
because that's where the money is or you
know I just need enough money and then
I'm in a good work-life balance out the
other softball team I'll play video
games I really believe I really believe
that somebody who's watching this right
now who obsesses on being on six
softball teams right now literally can
make 127 thousand dollars a year in ad
revenue and live events and a couple
other sponsorships and selling a couple
t-shirts by literally becoming the
authority on softball in America my son
who is a junior in high school is
spending a good peaceful summer
including right now today at a
university in Connecticut studying
computer system computer science
specifically focused on video game
design yeah
just of that I mean video game video
game culture at night when we were kids
like that like like to think it was a
mass industry I mean eSports is gonna be
bigger than baseball in this country in
20 years
eSports is going to be a bigger business
than major league baseball in 20 30
years from now I'll go 30 I'm gonna
hedge a little bit in 30 years ago I
mean that is incredible to me India
attea asks if you could swap out one
quality of your own for one of KC's and
vice versa
what would it be mine's very easy I
don't know if you know me well enough to
answer this question mine's very easy
I'm a wimp when it comes to
it'll stuff I don't ride skateboards and
on surf or ski I do very little risk
adventure I look at GoPros I'm like who
gives a rat's ass like that's not even
in my consideration set you know one
time I jumped off like a 50-foot cliff
in Jamaica I still can't believe I did
that like you know because there's a lot
of chicks there you know like sevens
like peer repair should college stuff I
mean like I mean everybody jumped you
know like some like eight year old jump
like alright so having a little bit of
an adventurous bone would be intriguing
to me I mean look I am super happy the
way I am but if if I have to answer the
question having a little bit of that
free spirit in this I think is really
attractive there I'm going to go really
specific character and that's your taste
and I for wine you know I'm like a I'm
an uneducated kid from a lower middle
class house yet I present myself as
someone who is fairly sophisticated but
when it comes to wine with all
conversations in this world lead to wine
I couldn't tell you which one came from
a box and which one came from Gary
cellar and that's something I really
appreciate you treat it like an art form
I have a feeling we're gonna have a
video maybe any in I think in twelve to
eighteen months from now we're gonna
have to like drink very high-end wine
while like jumping out of like a plane
or something we're just gonna come by
this not in that order
no no in that order we're gonna be real
good we may forget to parachute out
there'll be big news I'll probably get
the most press we've ever gotten through
you know we're gone great use of your
yeah we just drink - I'm glad to pull
the cord yeah um before we in this video
yes you're looking buff man crazy right
getting jacked what's happening
date time it's happening but you let me
look at this give me give me that give
him something give him something I
wasn't sure it says this is because I
have to carry this big ass camera around
all the time that's the reason why I
have to Zika has to support my career
case the guest always gets to ask the
question of the day what question I know
you're ready yet a pull one out the last
time don't repeat it you're trying to
call what it was some buying you some
time anything you'd like fire oh that I
asked the audience and they're going to
answer in the comments section okay um
how about something broad which is give
us give us some generic advice for how
we could be better communicators to you
Gary and I both have this platform that
we built but we have this big platform
that's a huge loudspeaker that we can
speak to a lot of people from what is it
that we don't talk about enough what is
it that we should be sharing more of
that could have a great more haft yeah
well yeah that stuff we hear and we
appreciate this is great thanks for be
on the show yeah of course any time ah
yeah I'll say for next one you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them
you